10 it's fantastic to see you here
tonight for the premiere a testament of
youth now what's it like taking on the
roles of real people yeah I mean it's
daunting particularly for as green and
actor as I am but it's also tremendously
exciting it's very flattering and you
feel very honored that that someone
trusts you with with with that duty
really but when we got on set it became
very apparent that everyone was taking
it very very seriously and everyone felt
they were there to do something to see
something hopefully really really good
so looking forward to seeing the
beautiful film I mean it's a very
touching story of course who said I mean
what was it that touched you in
particular about Vera about Edwards
stories well funnily well I mean I mean
the you know the inside their whole
story is very moving but the one thing
that was said to me on set that really
really really struck home was I've said
it before today but James said that they
were just real people and I think as he
as a young actor I'd kind of gone into
it thinking there's something removed
about playing people who lived 100 years
ago and I think what I hope is really
great about testament of you is that
they'll just feel like real ordinary
young people and I think that's it's
very in juliette Scripture and you don't
feel like you're reading some
long-forgotten relic or that was only
you know hundred years ago you feel like
you're reading real people who could be
living and breathing right now
I already Awards berths for unless
you're in that central role of Bureau
what do you think about that what you
think there's an awards buzz for her I
think it'd be sacrilege if she didn't
get it I mean she's a force of nature
and she's it so emotionally connected to
what she's doing and so hardworking and
committed you know those evenings where
we were staying in hotels and I was
deciding whether or not to have a pint
she was upstairs already in bed
so yeah I think any any accolade that is
showered upon olicity of a kind was well
deserved because very different things
coming it for me we've got the Kingsmen
Secret Service what kind of audiences
look forward to from that and what was
it like working with Colin Firth and
samuel l.jackson I mean yeah amazing I
still can't quite believe I still sort
of fall asleep thinking am I going to
wake up and it won't be the case anymore
did that actually happen yeah it was it
was it was wonderful and those guys oh
not only brilliant actors and iconic
movie stars but just really generous
lovely men and great people to work for
in terms of what you can expect from it
I think I might I hope that you can
respect fireworks you can expect
massively tailored suits lots of gadgets
guns coming up as well having Erie Tom
Hardy yeah legend me and Tom Hardy yeah
tell me I say me and Tom Hardy Tom Hardy
and a little bit of me but yes that will
come out next year and that should be
very different again but a really fun
piece with Tom Hardy doing something you
know equally kind of unseen before
playing - playing playing a set of twins
who were very very different
I play Ron crazed lover or one of what I
imagine was a string of lovers yeah yeah
- beautiful film
you